Boom. The bad guy just broke into your systemand you are hemorrhaging data. You have had a
data breach. How much is it going to costyou? How long is it going to take you to
get everything back up and operational again?Well, we answer those questions in the annual
cost of a data breach report. And what I wantto share with you today are the methodology
that we use in order to get these numbers.What some of the key findings from the report
are and then ultimately some recommendationsthat you can use in order to cut the cost of a
data breach and reduce the amount of time it takesto recover. So let's start off with methodology.
What did we do in order to get the informationthat we have so that you can have confidence
that the numbers I'm about to share withyou mean anything in the real world?
Well, we started off by contracing with anorganization called the Ponemon Institute,
and they do this work on behalf of IBM. Sothe clients who are answering these questions
are not answering directly to us. They feellike they can be candid in their responses.
And we've run this now for 18 years. So I'mgoing to suggest to you, some of you haven't
learned the lessons of the previous 17.So pay close attention to this one, please.
The clients that we interviewed, we talkedto more than 3000 individual clients,
Ponemon Institute did on our behalf. Andthose people represented 533 different
organizations. So the point here being is therewas a large number of people contributing their
information. We didn't just go out and askthree people and find out what they thought.
This is a large empirical base of data that we'rebasing all of this on. And another interesting
part of the methodology is the outliers wereexcluded. And what that means is if you think
about the cost of a data breach, some people willhave very minimal cost, They'll have a very small
breach and some people will have really huge ones. This one will be a gazillion dollars, This one
will be $0.25, I guess. And the point is we'reexcluding the ones on either extreme because
those would skew the numbers and they would makethe averages not look very realistic. So we take
those out, the very small, the very large, and wefocus in just on the normative case so that we can
have some lessons that we can apply elsewhere.Now, let's take a look at some of the key
findings that came out of this. First of all,4.4 or $5 million is the cost of a data breach
worldwide. That's the average cost. Some aremore, some are less. The ones that are more.
$10.43 million in the US. If you're ahealth care organization, that was the
highest of all the industries that we looked at. So if you're working in health care, I would say
pay special attention to this because that numberis not going to be sustainable to expensive.
Now, what were the things that were contributingto this? There's a lot of different ways that
data can be breached, a lot of differentways bad guys get in. So if we look at cost
of different types of attacks and frequencyof those, then you put those two together.
The things that are highest cost and highestfrequency are the ones that are contributing
most to those numbers. So what were they?Well, the top two, it turns out the top one
was phishing attacks. And just behind it wereattacks to deal with credential compromise. So
these are some things that if we want toreduce those numbers, we really need to
focus on these kinds of attacks scenarios. Now, what else did we learn from this? Some
other numbers that I think are important,maybe one of the most depressing numbers,
even more depressing than those numbers are thesenumbers. I've talked about this in previous videos
that the basic timeline of an attack. Soa bad guy comes in and does initially this
reconnaissance phase where he's looking andtrying to figure out what's going to happen.
Then there's an attack. That's the boom. Thenwe have a mean time to identify. That's how
long it takes for us to figure out that,in fact, we've been breached. And then we
have a mean time to contain. That's how long ittakes for us to resolve whatever the issue is.
And the thing that's really depressinghere, these two numbers taken together,
277 days, that's a really long time for thebad guy to be in your system using your data.
And then for you, once you realize it, to comeup and figure out how to fix this. The depressing
part about this is not only is that a long time,but it's been essentially the same number for
almost the last ten years. In other words, wekeep trying new technologies, new processes,
procedures. We promise we're going to do better.We're all going to try harder. But this number
remains. So clearly, we've got a lot of lessonsto learn if we're going to get ahead on this and
reduce costs and reduce the amount of time thatit takes to contain, to identify and contain.
All right. Let's move on to recommendations.That's the bad news. There's some good
news in the report as well. And some of that good news is
that I'm going to share with you the top threethings that made a difference in reducing the
cost of a data breach and those top threein order reverse order. So number three,
1.49 million a reduction came from good incident,response, planning, tools, procedures, processes,
training, all of that kind of stuff. If you've got good instant response,
you're doing things in this side and you're doingthe containment much better, and the quicker you
contain, the less it's going to cost thenext one 1.68 million. This this savings
from a good deployment of Devsecops. Devsecopsis basically breaking down the walls between
development and operations and inserting securitythroughout the process as part of a systemic view.
So we've got no longer throwing stuffover the wall. We've got development,
security and operations all working togetherthrough a continuous process of improvement.
Number one, to improve the cost of a databreach, in other words, reduce the cost.
This was the use of AI and automation, and thatmakes a lot of sense. We want to work smarter.
We want to work faster, more efficiently, ina more repeatable way. And that's what I and
automation allow us to do respectively.And if you take those numbers that and
look at just the A.I. and automation and seewhat difference did that in fact make. Well,
that's what these numbers here are. So fororganizations that really had no A.I. to any real
extent, really were not taking advantage of it.This was the cost for them, 5.36 million. The
ones who had done limited use of A.I.. Well, younotice a significant savings here down to about 4
million. And then for those who had an extensiveuse of A.I., it was down to 3.6 million. And one
of the other side benefits is that it was 108days reduction in the amount of time to resolve.
So the AI and automation not only reduced cost,it also reduced the response time and resolution
time. This is clearly a big winner. That'swhy you see the three stars and I'm going to
throw in a bonus. No extra charge. A bonusrecommendation that will also make a big
difference. And that's attack surface management.Attack surface management is basically trying to
look and see all the different things that youlook like to an attacker and reducing that.
Plugging the holes. And in some cases, fortifyingyour defenses. So attack surface management really
begins with awareness of what your attacksurface looks like. And then putting the
controls in place in order to make thosenot part of the attack surface anymore
and attack surface management organizations.According to the to the survey they did the
best with this reduced their time to contain.So that mean time to contain 83 days. That was
a significant number. If you can do somethinglike this, you're going to reduce the response.
You're going to reduce the cost. And if youdo all of these kinds of things, you're going
to make a huge difference in your data breachnumbers. So it turns out I'm going to give you
also a bonus finding that we got from the report.That's kind of a good news, bad news story here.
And that is of the organizations, 51% said theywould increase their spending in I.T. security
in cybersecurity. Good. They realized that we needto do something here and tools and better training
and things like that. They cost money, butthey make us money by saving us in these areas.
But I do have a question for the other49%. Did you not just read all of this?
Did you not hear? Please take a lookat the report because once you see it,
you're going to see the things that are going tomake a big difference and you're going to be able
to make a better impact for your organization.And that will impact the bottom line. So in the
end, I'm going to recommend that you take a lookat the report, the cost of a data breach report.
It's for free. So you can go to the followinglink and take a look, read through the results
and figure out what it is you need to do. What'sgoing to make the biggest difference in improving
the cost of the data breach for your organization?
Hey, before you go. Remember to hit like subscribe and click the bell
so that you're notifiedwhenever we come out with more videos.